Now I want to turn to the lecture and I'm going to start the lecture with,
with my true confession of the day.
Okay.
I did something a little insane and I'm not entirely sure how this was going to
work out.
Um,
I did it for you.
I basically on the syllabus it says that the title of this lecture is
citizenship and leadership or leadership and citizenship.
I don't even remember which one I put first.
Um,
and initially my idea had been when I wrote the syllabus for this course before
the semester even started.
Um,
well this is going to be a lecture that has something to do with new ways of,
of like how the revolution changed people's sense of themselves as citizens,
how people were behaving differently because of the approach of revolution.
And then because of the fighting of revolution.
And I was going to talk a little bit about crowd actions and about how the
revolution itself wouldn't really have been possible without crowd actions.
I've talked,
I know a little bit about mob actions and we've seen some inaction action.
Um,
so I was basically going to talk about how the revolution politicized people,
how it,
um,
on a mass scale for many different kinds of Americans brought them into the
public sphere,
made them think and act politically in a way that perhaps they hadn't before.
And then I was going to accompany that with a brief discussion about the elite
in this environment being on the one hand,
appreciative of the sort of mass popular involvement because there would be no
revolution without it.
That is the revolution.
But on the other hand,
they're elite folks,
so they're all,
some of them at least are a little nervous about all of this sort of popular
sentiment and crowd action.
And I even had find my favorite,
arrogant,
aristocratic quote.
Okay.
So I even found random arrogant,
uh,
elite guy coach.
I'm in 1774 who observed with true disdain the mob begin to think and reason.
This is Gouverneur Morris,
who actually has a really great sense of humor,
but also he's really kind of the aristocratically disdainful.
And he says he believes with fear and trembling that if the disputes with Great
Britain continue,
we shall be under the worst of all possible Dominion's we shall be under the
domination of a riotous mob.
Okay.
So Gouverneur Morris is an extreme example of some sort of elite concern about
what the revolution means.
What does it mean that people are rising up?
So that was,
that was going to be today's lecture.
That was my plan.
But when I started thinking about the lecture and thinking about just preparing
it and tweaking it,
and again,
I had last thought about it back in December.
And you know,
when you make a syllabus for a course,
you think about the course.
Yeah.
Outline it.
You think it's all going to go well,
and then you get halfway through the course and sometimes different things seem
exciting to you.
Um,
or you suddenly get a gut feeling that,
wow,
I was going to have a really abstract discussion today and I don't want to have
an abstract.
Gotcha.
I want us to be grounded in the actual revolution.
Um,
all of those things that happened to me when I was thinking about today's
lecture.
Um,
and I decided at the absolute last minute,
I wasn't going to give that lecture at literally the absolute last minute today,
this morning for me it was like a reality show called the lecture and I was like
Freeman three hours research and write a new lecturer.
So I was sort of frantically at my desk.
I'm so not only did I research and write a new lecture,
but it's based entirely on primary research.
So I mean I really researched,
you'll hear,
um,
and I'm going to explain it in one,
but what I'm actually going to be lecturing long,
which is related to what I'm supposed to be lecturing on.
But basically I just came up with something that to me felt more interesting,
more immediate is going to show some of the same things I would have been
talking about in my big,
broad,
general way with my leadership and citizenship lecture.
But instead I'm actually going to base it on real people in a real place put of
really showing you as the is unfolding.
What happens to people in this place and how do events in ideas affect them.
So I,
when I said,
I hope I have a minute or two at the end given that I like literally was
printing this out as I was grabbing my coat to run here.
Um,
hopefully this is all going to work and electrical goes swimming lead.
This is true confessions,
right?
I should never get up in front of you and say,
maybe my lecture will die,
die.
Um,
but,
but I'm going to,
I'm going to aim for a grand slam and we'll try.
Um,
but one way or another,
what I am going to do today is get across some of the ideas in a concrete way
that I had been thinking I was going to approach it in an abstract way and that
just didn't get me excited this morning.
So,
um,
it's a little experiment for me.
Um,
and what I'm going to do,
my little experimental thing is I'm actually going to be talking about
citizenship and leadership and the American revolution by focusing on Yale and
new haven.
This was my brilliant thought for the morning.
Ah,
I can focus right here like I can talk about us here now and look at throughout
the 17th seventies some of the ways in which people were actually experiencing
the revolution,
some of the ways in which the revolution was getting them to take action,
what it is they were doing,
why they were doing it,
who was doing it,
who was taking action.
So again,
we're not just going to be looking at three elite guys in a room sort of writing
proclamation,
but we're actually going to be talking about students and the people of new
haven.
So that's my,
my experimental lecture for this morning.
And as you're going to see average new haven residents took strong action at an
early point in the growing conflict between the colonies and Great Britain.
So really in a main and a sort of major way,
what we're going to be looking at is their story today.
The story of average people in new haven mean students are kind of above average
because they would have been for more elevated families.
We're going to be looking at students too,
but we're going to be looking at a lot of what's happening just in the town of
new haven,
which in a way is the best way to look at the revolution,
which is really how it's unfolding on the ground.
Plus,
this means I get to talk about the British invasion of new haven,
which I've been waiting for my moment.
I've never actually talked about it in this class before I discovered it when I
was writing the introductory lecture.
And then having discovered it,
it was like,
okay,
well now I have to find a way to talk about the innovation of new haven.
So after I had my brilliant idea,
I realized
he's,
I get to talk about the check on new haven in today's lecture.
So that will be there today too.
Okay.
So,
um,
let's actually turn now to Yale in new haven,
at the opening of the revolution.
And most of the lecture today is gonna focus on the 1770s.
Um,
but I will mention in starting that Yale students were certainly caught up in
all of the fervor that I've been talking about in past lectures.
And I know I mentioned once before,
um,
that Gail students decided,
uh,
in protests at one point to give up importing fine wines,
the sacrifice on the part of Yale students.
Um,
in the 1760s ELL students,
like many other people throughout the colonies were engaged in acts of sort of
personal protests like that,
you know,
giving something up.
Okay.
Maybe on the part of the El students it was just fine wines,
but still,
um,
or on another occasion,
in 1769,
um,
in response to the Townson acts and then the idea of non importation,
the senior class of Yale came up with the following proclamation,
which they made publicly,
the senior class of Yale College.
Have you Nanimo Asley agreed to make their appearance at the next public
commencement when they are to take their first degree,
holy dressed in the manufacturers of our own country and desire.
This public notice may be given of their resolution so their parents and friends
may have sufficient time to be providing homespun clothes for them.
It's like we're making a proclamation,
mom,
send me some clothes,
but the,
you know,
the,
the feeling was there
and even better,
they want their parents to provide homespun clothes that none of them may be
obliged to.
The hard necessity of unfashionable singularity by wearing important cloth.
Okay,
mom,
if you don't send me clothes,
I'm going to have to wear in Puerto clothes and I'm going to be really unpopular
guilting the parents.
Okay.
But anyway,
that's Yale students with the 1760s actually making acts of protest,
organizing themselves into active protest.
Now,
Yale isn't unique in this way.
Actually throughout the period colonial colleges in a variety of different
places were places that tended to brew sentiment,
political sentiment that was rebellious or outrage at some of the acts being
imposed by the British government.
Actually Yale and Harvard and the College of New Jersey,
which is now Princeton,
tended to be particularly well known as,
as sort of seed beds of unrest,
like particularly angry students who had strong political feelings.
Um,
but there were other colleges as well,
um,
where the students really were provoked to acts of protest in a variety of
different ways.
I mean,
and I,
I this morning in researching for this lecture,
I found a bunch of Princeton College of New Jersey students who decided that no
one in Princeton should be drinking tea.
So they went out into the town and just personally like forced their way into
people's houses and when they found tea,
they burned it.
That would be really popular.
Right.
And then one of them said something like that was a real frolic.
The child must have been very pleased.
Um,
I think,
uh,
in another college,
the commencement exercises,
you know,
the speeches at the students gave at a commencement exercise,
um,
at a pretty early point,
actually,
they debated one for one and against the possibility of independence.
I think that was like in 1769 you had students at one college who decided that
would be what would be happening as their commencement ceremony is they would
have that debate.
It's a really early point and again,
pretty,
pretty radical.
So we're kind of looking at a longstanding pattern of college students being
bold and radical during times of political controversy and political unrest.
Um,
and this is happening throughout the colonies in this period.
And it kind of makes sense.
You have a cluster of people together and you have a variety of different
avenues,
ways for students to make their thoughts known.
Um,
so colleges,
and as I said,
particularly Yale became known as the sort of seed bed of sedition as one
loyalist said of Yale and the 17th seventies.
The college is no longer remarkable for its scholarship,
but instead for it's persecuting spirit,
it's Republican principles,
it's intolerance in religion.
But this is a person of loyalists,
sympathies.
It says,
you know,
he used to be great.
It's all downhill now.
They have those crazy,
wild radical students.
Um,
or as a British officer put it in 1779 he happens to be the British officer who
invaded new haven.
Um,
quote that place.
New Haven is a spacious and very considerable town.
It has the largest university in America and Mike with propriety be styled the
parent and nurse of rebellion.
We are the parent understand rebellion like Yale.
Hey Gail.
Okay.
Um,
but this is not to say that colleges in this period,
our little isolated seed beds of rebellion and everybody else's sort of sitting
around widdling pieces of wood thinking,
oh,
I wonder what the British are doing today.
Right.
It's not as,
so the colleges are isolated from the communities or that the college is only
noticed the communities when they're going to go out and burn random citizens t
as they did in New Jersey.
Um,
there were,
obviously there were connections between whatever was going on in these colleges
and whatever was going on in these towns.
And we're going to see that play out a couple of times,
uh,
in this lecture today.
Sometimes things that went on in the town spread their way onto the Gail campus.
I'm an example of this is in the late 1760s when there was a rally on the new
haven town green against British policy,
and the Yale students apparently attended that rally and got very stirred up by
the rally and decided to continue it on the Yale campus.
Um,
at which point a big group of students decided it would be a really great idea
to declare their political sentiments by toasting English radical John Wilkes.
And they decided not,
and I don't know where this number came from,
God,
I didn't have time to research where the number came from,
but you'll hear why I questioned it.
They decided that they would toast John Wilkes 45 times.
Okay,
that's 45 drinks.
So I'm one observer who I gather from my research this morning,
had loyalists sympathies,
said that instead of drinking 45 glasses and honor of Wilkes and liberty,
the Yale students drank themselves 45 degrees in extreme oh drunk.
So we got plastered Yale students like,
yeah,
liberty.
But that's,
you know,
the towns spreading into the realm of the gown.
Now in the 1660s,
we're seeing these sort of public demonstrations,
new haven,
Yale campus protesting policies,
but not anything that dramatic happening,
but things become worse as relations between England and its colonies became
worse.
And as,
um,
actions became more aggressive on both sides.
People in new haven,
as in a lot of other places became more aggressive in their politics and became
stronger in their actions.
They made bolder decisions.
And a great example of that is again,
here in new haven,
1774,
a group of about 60 men from new haven,
normal townspeople.
And then to talk about them in a moment,
um,
decided that they were going to hire someone to teach them military exercises so
that hopefully they would learn something and it's somewhere down the road if
they had to be,
they could organize themselves into a military unit and protect the town of new
haven.
Okay.
So here's 60 random people in new haven who hire someone.
I think they paid him like,
you know,
$3 a lesson or something to teach them how to drill and what to do with guns and
had him walk in formation and basic military thing so that they would know what
to do in case they ever actually had to fight again.
That's kind of a,
that's going to have a dramatic action.
I mean that's a big step to take.
Okay,
now I need to be militarily drilling in case I need to defend my family,
my property and my town.
So that certainly gives you a sense of what it felt like.
What was sort of floating in the air at this time for people in new haven to
take that kind of an action.
In early 1775,
they met as a group and they decided that they would really organize themselves
into a real military unit as opposed to you guys taking lessons on how to drill.
Um,
so they met,
they voted on uniforms,
they figured out the best way to obtain arms so that they'd know where they'd be
getting them from.
And then not long after that they actually wrote to the Connecticut state
assembly and said that they quote anxious for the safety of our country and
desirous of contributing all in their power to the support of our just rights
and liberties have formed themselves into a military company and then added that
they wanted the Connecticut state assembly to officially make them sort of
district military units.
So they wanted official recognition from the Connecticut state assembly.
Again,
really interesting random 60 guys like maybe we better know something military.
Then after that they decide,
okay,
well maybe we actually had better.
We can organize ourselves so that this will actually be real.
Hey,
now that we've organized ourselves,
we can actually get like state recognition.
So that will be on call and armed and ready in case something bad happens.
Again,
kind of an interesting chain of events,
series of personal decisions on the part of those random 60 men.
Now let's look for a minute at who they are.
One of them apparently owned a hat store on Chapel Street.
One of them was a barber who is described quote as a rather eccentric person.
I don't know what that means,
although I was dying to have the time to figure out why the barber was rather
eccentric.
But we have an eccentric Barbara who is one of those 60,
I'm a chair maker,
a few sailors,
someone who was just described as a man of leisure.
Um,
it's an interesting to ponder what that means.
I'm a lawyer,
a few grocers.
There was a grocer who lived on state street and a grocer who lived on the
corner of Chapel and church.
And of course for me researching this this morning,
it's really fascinating to be finding people living in places that of course we
all know,
you know,
I mean that's always cause exactly.
Picked your,
oh,
the corner of chapel in church.
I know exactly where that person lived.
Um,
one person worked in the new haven bank,
um,
and decided that he wasn't really very skilled at horsemanship and in case that
they were going to fight,
he probably would need to know how to be really good on horseback.
So apparently he regularly took his horse into his yard and practice on the
horse and private and took it into his yard.
So no one would see that he was the guy who had to practice horsemanship,
but he was sort of there doing his own little private drilling so that he'd be
prepared in case there was actual fighting.
Okay.
So there you see a group of people,
all different levels of society,
lawyers,
man of leisure,
eccentric barber's chair makers,
groceries,
all different levels of society who have all come together for this one purpose
and have gone over a series of months here to increasingly become more and more
serious about what it is that they're doing.
So it certainly tells you something about the mindset in new haven in early 1775
and not only in new haven as we've already heard in the course,
things became more dramatic on April 21st,
1775 when news of the battle of Lexington arrived in new haven.
And what was interesting to me this morning was when I was reading accounts of
people in new haven reporting when they heard this news.
Um,
several of them literally stayed at the precise time of day,
like at noon on the 21st someone told me,
I mean,
they actually had it down to the hour and the minute when they heard about the
events at Lexington,
which to me was really telling because it's what you do afterwards when
something really momentous or tragic or notable or historic happens,
you think,
you know,
where was I when that happened?
You know,
where it was.
Like,
where was I when the challenger blew up?
You know,
I was,
I was a receptionist at an advertising agency sitting at my desk.
Um,
but,
but you know,
I remembered that because I remember everyone around me getting upset and it was
a big deal.
And,
and so here are these people kind of doing the same thing,
remembering after the fact.
I remember where I was,
it was noon on the 21st when we heard in new haven that the British had actually
fired on colonists in Lexington in new haven.
A Yale student wrote in his diary today,
tidings of the battle of Lexington,
which is the first engagement with the British troops arrived at new haven.
This fill the country with alarm and rendered it impossible for us to pursue our
studies to any profit.
And this is the moment I mentioned on Tuesday's lecture when Benedict Arnold,
who's one of the men in that group of 60 guys who decided they'd better arm and
drill.
He's one of those men when he decides that they need arms and they're going to
march to Massachusetts and he sorta fights the new haven town committee to get
the key so that he can grab arms and go march with his men up to Massachusetts
on linking today's lecture with Tuesday's lecture.
Very proud.
Um,
and actually he and his men,
as they were preparing to leave town and sort of go off to fight,
they drew up an agreement,
which they all signed a sort of pledge to each other and a,
and a public statement as to what they were doing and why they were doing it,
which is worth quoting because you'll hear in the middle of,
it's something you might not expect to see in a statement being drawn up by a
bunch of guys who've just by force armed themselves and are going to go march to
Massachusetts to fight the British.
So this is the beginning of their statement,
be it known that we,
the subscribers having taken up arms for the relief of our brethren and defense
of theirs as well as our just rights and privileges declare to the world that
we,
from our hearts disavow every thought of rebellion to His Majesty as Supreme
Head of the British Empire.
Okay.
They've taken up arms,
they're marching to fight the British.
And the first thing they say in the first sentence of their proclamation is
we're not rebelling against the king.
That when I read this I thought,
wow,
that's,
and I've been saying over and over again in class,
it's,
all of these things are mixed in together.
People who are upset,
they're angry at what's going on,
they're angry British policy and they're loyal to the king and they're thinking
about independence,
but they're unsure about independence and they're still linked to England.
And in a way that statement is a great example of that.
Guys who were holding guns and about to march to fight are being sure to state
that they are not rebelling against His Majesty,
His supreme head of the British empire or up there.
They don't want to be accused of opposition to his legal authority and shall on
every occasion manifest to the world by our conduct this to be our fixed
principle so they're not rebelling against the king.
Instead they said that they were quote driven to the last necessity and obliged
to have recourse to arms in defense of our lives and liberties.
So they're saying we're not like rebels who are out to rebel against the king.
We're actually,
we've been driven to this by what's going on in Massachusetts and we're
protecting ourselves,
but this is a defensive act and not an aggressive act.
And then when you read a little further on in the statement after all of this
sort of noble,
lofty sentiment,
they then promise each other they're not going to get drunk or gamble or swear.
It's like down to practicalities now that we've declared our purpose of the
world,
no heavy drinking.
Okay.
The next day,
April 22nd,
1775 classes at Yale were suspended and a lot of students went home.
Some a few actually went off to fight.
So you can kind of see the way that the wind is blowing in new haven.
You can imagine given these sorts of events potentially how much fun it would
have been to be a college student with loyalist leanings at this particular
moment.
It would not have been very fun and sure enough in 1775 there was that student.
I discovered that student this morning.
There was a,
I don't know if he's the only one,
but he's the guy who got in trouble.
There was one college student here at Yale who was a declared loyalist 1775 he
did not make other Yale students very happy.
He must've been loud about being a loyalist,
otherwise,
don't know how it would have been so obvious to everyone that he was a loyalist,
but the,
the large chunk of the Gail student body decided to have a meeting to debate
what should be done about this student.
Obviously things are not going to go well for the student.
What should we do about this student?
They decide that they are going to formerly denounce him as publicly as quote an
enemy to his country and that no one will be allowed to socialize with his
student ever again.
Okay.
They've just ostracizes,
can you imagine?
Sorry,
you've just been entirely ostracized from every other person at Yale University
because we don't like your politics.
So when I first found this this morning,
I was like,
oh,
you know,
poor guy.
Like what?
And I couldn't figure out what happened next and I just felt sorry for him.
But then like found a little bit more about him and I felt a little less sorry
for him cause he took action.
Apparently he was from new haven.
This particularly loyal a student.
So learning that he had been ostracized by all of the Yale student buddy,
he went home and got sent up some of his townie friends to go back to Yale and
beat up some Yale students,
which they did.
Uh,
and then the Yale students got really mad at this,
apparently an armed themselves with clubs and we're going to go attack these
townies.
Um,
when the Yale President Neftali Daggett intervened,
it was like,
okay,
we're done with the war now.
Like nice idea,
done with the worth of the fighting stop.
And at eventually,
I don't know when the loyalist withdrew from Yale though.
You can't blame him at this point.
Okay.
So we have people in new haven forming military units and marching off to fight.
We have students ostracizing,
met one loan loyalist student not long after this,
Yale students organize their own military and actually began training.
And not long after that,
the new haven town meeting voted.
And here's what they declared,
quote that the governor be desired to permit 100 stands of arms to be lodged in
the library for the use of a company in Yale College that should accompany in
college,
be formed and accoutered.
They draw half a pound of powder to each man.
Okay.
Yeah,
I'll,
students have just started militarily drilling and the new haven town meeting
has voted to store arms in the Yale Library in case the students actually get it
together and form an organizing unit.
They'll have arms stored in the Yale Library ready in case fighting has to
happen,
which again,
is really dramatic kind of a decision to make.
It's,
it's stated in a very plain way and the documents that I found,
but that's a dramatic kind of a decision.
So again,
you can see even just in that example how some of these really general ideas
I've been talking about over the course of many,
many lectures,
building resentments,
shared fears,
continued loyalty to the king,
are playing out here on a small scale in new haven in real life.
Now,
the Yale military unit apparently had its main moment of glory that same year in
1775 when George Washington,
who was the now the newly named commander and chief of the continental army,
actually pass through new haven on his way to join the continental army outside
of Boston.
And I'll be talking about George Washington in the next lecture.
So I'm feeling very fancy once again,
that I have magically somehow seemed as though this lecture was really planned
all along.
Um,
but apparently Connecticut newspapers noted that,
you know,
people from new haven went out.
They wanted to see Washington and they wanted to see what was going on.
Um,
they wanted to watch the Yale students do a drill,
which they did apparently a formal drill in front of Washington and his escort.
Um,
Noah Webster dictionary Webster was a Yale freshmen that year.
And in later years he told people that he remembered that event.
He remembered Washington watching the drilling students.
He remembered that the,
that the body of the military body of students escorted Washington out of town
and Webster said that he himself played some kind of music to accompany the
marching of the Yale students with Washington out of town.
So he remembered that a long time later.
It's sort of a memorable moment from the war
now in the interest of time,
I'm going to leap to 1777 because in 1777 warfare now is unfolding throughout
the northern states.
And some people then began to conclude that actually staying in new haven and
studying at Yale might be just too dangerous for Yale students because new haven
wasn't exposed port,
which we're going to see in about five minutes.
It isn't exposed port.
So the Yale authorities sent students out to different towns.
They didn't close the,
they just said,
okay,
we're going to send students to random places in Connecticut where they will be
safer than they are in new haven.
So freshmen went to Farmington,
sophomores and juniors went to Glastonbury and seniors went to Weathersfield.
I cannot tell you why those particular places seemed like a logical places,
but you and your class were sent to random place to continue your studies.
Um,
on their way out.
Gail officials asked the town to please protect the abandoned college buildings
from troops,
American or British troops,
and some library books were moved inland to protect them in case troops came to
new haven.
So again,
people are feeling there's a potential real threat here.
Gail eventually did come back into session in new haven,
not without serious problems.
And again,
you're going to see the playing out here of something I've talked about before.
I've talked before about the problems of supplying the army.
It was hard to get food.
People weren't sort of giving up food and supplies to the army.
Apparently they was really hard for people to get food and supplies into Yale
too,
that people just weren't who,
whatever sources of supplies had been serving Gail in the past.
We're no longer doing that in a time of war.
So in 1778,
Yale sent out the following notice to parents of Yale students.
September 30 1778 the steward of Yale College hereby requests the parents and
guardians of the students to assist in furnishing a supply of provisions.
Okay.
Parents,
would you please send food?
We don't have a lot.
We really need it.
Um,
without which it would be very difficult if not impracticable for him to subsist
the scholars,
the ensuing winter,
a generous and full price shall be allowed and paid either in money or their
sons.
Quarter bills,
I'll shall be most agreeable.
Okay.
Please send us food.
We don't have any.
And if you do,
we'll either pay you or we won't charge you tuition for your steel,
your sons.
So please give us food.
Which again,
can you imagine being the parent who gets the,
sorry.
There was no food for your son
since some net while you're sending the homespun clothes,
send the food to.
Okay,
so the war is a real presence even on the college campus drilling students
fighting men gun stored in the Yale Library,
people having a hard time getting food and supplies.
1779 is when things become much worse because that is the peak year of violence
in new haven.
That is the year when the British invaded you haven.
And as her styles,
who's president of Yale at the time,
noted in his diary the events as they unfolded.
And it again,
it's really interesting to see his diary entries.
He later wrote another account that had full sentences,
but to me what was more interesting,
and I'll read some of them here where some of his diary entries,
because they're really immediate and he's,
he's kind of recording his reaction to events as they're happening.
So on July 4th,
1779 he says,
he heard news that there was a British fleet of ships that had been seen,
your Bridgeport and supposedly rumor said it was heading to new haven.
So again,
being responsible president of Yale,
he,
he asks for militia to be sent in case this is actually true.
They're going to need some real soldiers.
But he writes in his diary,
not believe the enemy intended landing.
Okay?
He hears the rumor and he takes action,
but he actually literally cannot believe that the British are actually going to
get off the shifts and a tap.
I can't be real,
can't be really happening.
The next day,
July 5th styles using a telescope says that he saw the ships distinctly from the
steeple of college chapel and he continues,
began to remove all property militia meeting Tory's calm with telescope from the
tower or steeple,
clearly saw the boats putting off from the ship and landing a little after
sunrise.
He sees that the smaller boats going off of these ships with soldiers to land on
the shore.
Immediately I sent off college records and papers and a bag of my own things,
sent his family away the next day,
July six styles rights enemy paraded sailors came on shore and took their turn
at plunder.
I'm going to continue a couple of days here and then go back to the actual
invasion.
Just cause the series of things he writes here are interesting and then they
become weirdly personal,
which again reminds you that this is a real person's experience.
He says,
July 7th 11:00 PM enemy landed and burnt Fairfield,
July 8th removing my furniture.
He's now moving this furniture out of Yale,
removing my furniture,
broke my Fahrenheit thermometer,
which I've had since 1762 I was like,
oh,
okay,
you'll sorry,
you're moving your furniture right now.
He's broke his thermometer.
July 12th the whole town moving and then July 23rd this little tiny reminder
that Yale is still an institution that exists.
July 23rd style spent the day writing diplomas onto parchment like,
yeah,
I know this,
this whole attack thing.
I've still got students and they still have to graduate,
so I'm going to write off their diplomas,
which I think is really kind of striking.
Okay.
Let's turn back for a minute to look at precisely what happened.
As the British invaded new haven.
Apparently they decided to attack the Connecticut shore to draw some of
Washington's troops away from white plains,
New York,
where I guess they were.
And that was,
I guess,
a strong position to hold.
So the British thought,
well,
if they attack the Connecticut shore,
they'll entice Washington to send some of his troops to Connecticut.
And that way maybe they can defeat them on both fronts.
And New haven ends up being the first target in this plan.
So on July 5th,
the British debark in new haven harbor,
they had about 2000 soldiers.
Um,
one part of the troops was going to enter new haven from east haven,
and the other part was going to enter from west haven styles wrote in his diary,
perhaps one third of the adult male inhabitants flew to arms and went out to
meet them a quarter removed out of town doing nothing.
The rest remained unmoved,
partly Tory's,
partly timid wigs.
And then he adds that some of the Tories armed themselves and then went out to
fight with the British.
That's a great example of how you know,
our,
our think,
our impulse is to say,
Whoa,
the people where you're noted and unity against the British,
it's like,
well,
no,
the entire town wasn't big lump,
a big lump of rebels.
It was people with different ideas and you just styles and that one little
sentence he has people going to fight with the British people are going to fight
against the British.
He has people sort of not knowing what to do and kind of just staying in town
and then people not wanting to do anything,
just wanting to get themselves out of there.
All sort of happening.
At the same time,
people are making decisions,
some pretty dramatic decisions and they're having to make them spur of the
moment and you can see them and a lot of cases here taking a side,
taking a formal side in a way that could have pretty dire consequences.
Gail immediately was dismissed and some students immediately ran for home.
Um,
supposedly according to a diary,
one student,
a sophomore instead of going home,
decided to go to a nearby town and read Blackstone's commentaries.
Why that made sense?
I don't know.
What are the British are coming?
I think I'll go to Fairfield and read Blackstone.
No.
Um,
and in later years he said he so enjoyed himself reading Blackstone during that
period that he decided to become a lawyer right there and then.
Okay.
It's like this one lone little reading comp student in the midst of not a lot of
other reading come students from what I could tell,
unlike that little Blackstone student,
um,
a volunteer company of about 70 Yale students,
which is roughly half of the student body at that point formed to fight.
They were led by Captain James Hillhouse.
He is indeed you haven hill house.
Um,
he was a Yale graduate of a few years before,
so he's not that much older than these men.
Um,
and again,
senior who ends up being one of these fighting Gail students offers an account
of what happened at this point.
He says,
um,
he,
he knows that troops landed in the south part of West haven about five miles
from the center of the town.
College was of course broken up and the students with many of the inhabitants
prepared to flee on the morrow into the neighboring country to give more time
for preparation.
And especially for the removal of goods.
A volunteer company of about a hundred young men was formed,
not with the expectation of making any serious stand against such a force,
but simply of retarding are diverting.
It's march.
So the students form,
they don't think they're going to like beat the British,
but maybe they can delay them a little bit in common with others of the
students.
I was one of the number,
and I will remember the surprise.
We felt the next morning,
July 5th as we were marching over westbridge towards the enemy to see doctor
Daggett,
who's the former president of Yale,
Neftali Daggett,
who's now a professor of divinity.
So he's a Yale professor,
has surprised me where the next morning to see doctor Daggett writing furiously
by us on his old black mirror with his long fowling piece in his hand,
ready for action.
We knew the old gentleman had studied the matter thoroughly and satisfied his
own mind is to the right and propriety of fighting it out.
But we were not quite prepared to see him come forth.
It's so gallon to style to carry its principles into practice.
So they see that this professor like a riding off with his gun,
like go on a flight.
The British like wow,
that's pretty impressive.
And I think in the first lecture I mentioned this instead,
it was the president of Yale writing out Daggett had retired as president.
So for the sake of accuracy,
he's now not president,
but it professor writing off to fight the British with his gun.
So now the student goes on giving him a hardy cheer.
As he passed,
we turned down towards West haven at the foot of the Milford Mills while he
Daggett uh,
send it a little to the west and took his station in a copes of wood where he
seemed to be Rican ordering the enemy,
like one who was determined to bide his time.
As we passed on towards the south,
we met and advanced guard of the British.
And taking our stand at a line of fence.
We fired upon them several times and then chase them the length of three or four
fields as they retreated until we suddenly found ourselves involved with the
main body.
Okay.
So there's like a couple of soldiers or like get them.
Oh and endanger of being surrounded.
It was now our turn to run and we did for our lives passing by Dr Daggers in his
station on the hill.
We were treated rapidly across Westbridge,
which was instantly taken down by persons who stood ready for the purpose to
prevent the enemy from entering the town by that road.
Okay,
so that's where his account ends.
Now we're going to pick it up with Daggett who offered his own account
afterwards of what happens.
Okay.
On Monday morning,
the fifth instant,
the town of new haven was Jesse alarmed with the threatening appearance of a
speedy invasion from the enemy.
Numbers went out arm to oppose them.
Having gone as far as I suppose with sufficient,
I turned down the hill to gain a little covert of bushes,
which I had in my eye.
But to my great surprise,
I saw the enemy,
which nears than I expected.
They're advanced guard being a little more than 20 rods,
distant with plain open ground between us.
They instantly fired upon me,
which they continued till I had run a dozen rods discharging,
not less than 15 or 20 balls at me alone.
However,
through the preserving providence of God,
I escaped from them all on hurt and gained the little covert at which I aimed,
which concealed me from their view.
While I could plainly see them through the woods and bushes advancing towards me
within 12 yard rods,
I singled out.
One of them took aim and fired upon him.
Okay,
so he takes one shot.
I loaded my musket again,
but determined not to discharge it anymore.
As I saw,
I could not escape from them and I determined to surrender myself as a prisoner.
So he's like charged out with his gun.
He takes one shot and he's like,
what am I doing?
I'm like a guy with a gun and the British army,
like,
what am I doing?
It's like,
okay,
I'll surrender myself as a prisoner.
I begged for quarter and that they would spare my life.
They drew near to me,
I think to only a number one on my right hand,
the other on my lift,
the fury of infernos glowing in their faces.
They called me a damned old rebel and swore they would kill me instantly.
They demanded quote,
what did you fire upon us for?
I love the question,
why are you shooting at us?
You've old crazy man sitting in the bushes.
I replied,
because it is the exercise of war
that did not impress the British.
Um,
and apparently they actually,
they didn't treat him very well,
so they,
one of them like pretended to stab at him with his band net and actually like
stabbed him a little bit and some of them sort of get him on the head.
And you know,
there's a long account here,
which I don't have time to read in which he talks about,
you know,
this guy hit me in the head and that guy hit me in the shin.
And then,
um,
then some guy hit me with a barrel of his gun and he actually,
he ends up being forced to march at the head of the British troops back to new
haven from wherever he is.
And he says,
I think in his account,
I finally,
I saw the new haven green and I was so happy.
I was like back in new haven,
but I think he,
oh,
and they also,
I should say they stole his shoes,
his knee buckles,
his pocket handkerchief and a little old tobacco box.
So they also just stripped him of whatever he had.
But he actually,
I think was kind of badly hurt.
And he's sick for a while and then a couple of years later he dies and people
later said that maybe he died because of injuries sustained at that moment after
the crazy charge of one guy,
you know,
the noble professor going off to fight the British
troops entered new haven proper a little afternoon after one last skirmish where
Wailey and Dixwell meat was it the last little skirmish.
And then the British entered,
they entered new haven and immediately began to plunder loyalist and rebel
houses alike,
breaking windows and doors carrying off valuables as styles described it.
Plender rape,
murder van heading in delicacies toward the sex.
Okay.
Women are not being treated respectfully.
Insolence and abuse and insult or the inhabitants in general.
One woman later recalled that a British soldier and town cut off her necklace to
keep and stole her shoe buckles.
Someone who lived on State Street said he was sitting in his door on state
street as the British came and he saw a British officer come riding down elm
street and turn upstate street towards grove.
And then he saw someone he knew from east haven ride over holding a musket,
which he leveled and fired at the British officer who fell off his horse and
sort of crawled into someone's garden.
At which point the east haven guy grabbed the officer's horse and run away.
So it's like I shot me someone from the British army and I got a horse to some
people fled town.
One man who was stuck in town with his wife because she was too ill to run,
saw British officers entered town and apparently went up to one and ask for
protection.
And the officer asked,
are you a friend to King George?
And the man said,
I am.
So his house was not attacked,
but apparently he was not a friend of King George.
He was not a Tori.
So for their after in town,
he was someone who was highly unpopular because he had,
I suppose in a sense,
sold himself out to protect his house.
Again,
a a sort of decision of the moment that makes sense,
but then had implications.
Some new haven loyalists actually fled with the British army,
which as I left,
actually,
they left a lot of destruction in their wake.
Okay,
so what have we seen today?
We've definitely seen how ideas and events happening in places pretty far
removed from new haven are distilling their way down right here.
Yale College,
New Haven,
Connecticut,
and really driving people to take action.
Sometimes pretty dramatic action.
We've seen average citizens,
average people from new haven stirred to act,
merchants,
lawyers,
sailor,
shoemakers students.
We've seen how the coming of war reveal all kinds of divisions among local
people as well as unity,
because people did have to make choices of all kinds.
So basically we've seen in this one little real life example how the coming of
the revolution and then the carrying out of the revolution drove average people
to become politically active and also militarily active to think through their
options,
to decide what they really believed.
And then in many cases to take a stand.
So professor Daggett,
the student says,
we know he'd been thinking about it and he'd been thinking about what he wanted
to do.
And he had decided that if pushed,
he would fight with students.
Kind of surprised he's actually heading out with a gun.
But again,
the student knows that Daggett was thinking through what his actions were going
to be.
And then he watches him take action like the loyalists who left new haven with
the British.
Again,
a really dramatic action.
So it just this little sort of case study of new haven and Yale,
you can see how citizenship and leadership came to have different meanings,
how people were understanding what they were supposed to be doing as citizens in
a different way as they lived.
The experience of fighting a revolution.
Okay.
I ended that on time.
I even read my,
I'm so impressed with myself,
the instant lecture,
I'm okay.
And I ended two minutes early.
So you have time to get your midterms.
Have a wonderful spring break and I will see you after.